Hi, Charles.
>> Hey, Michael.
How's it going?
>> Good, do you want to learn about
temporal difference learning today?
>> You know what I'd like to do?
I'd like to learn about temporal
difference learning today.
>> Perfect, because that is the plan.
And in fact, I need you to actually take
a little bit of a break and read Sutton.
>> What you mean the entire thing?
>> Yeah it's just a paper.
There's the Barto and Sutton book,
and Sutton and Barto book, but
this is actually the paper where he
introduces temporal difference learning.
>> Okay so
you want me to go read that now.
>> Yeah.
I can wait, you can just pause me.
>> How about I pretend I read it and
then you take me on
a odyssey of discovery.
>> Perfect.